こんにちははじめ社長の動画です
後輩に楽しいアプリを
聞きました
こちらですさっそくみんなで遊びましょう
[音楽]
てぐらいに私はい9号7号そういうのがすごいと日なんです時なんかまずで紹介され
ました
こちら号室5オンラインてやつがすごい面白いんでやってみてくださいと言われたんで
すってやっていこうと思います
これからは俳句を詠むならオンラインでおすごい数で評価が保守54.3なんで
ちょっとおもしろそうですねやってみましょうか開く
おーすげーシンプルですね号室5オンラインタップで監視
[音楽]
みんなで読むごーしちごって
1人出すもんじゃなかったのかちょっとみんな読んでみましょう
はい
マッチングするまでマッチングすんの
えっ
マッチングするのマッチングで俳句するって取ることだ何かどの程度をねっ
金玉タマとマッチング抹茶ラテ案などは最初の5文字最後のご無事を見ますか
あの
あ最初の防除入力してくださいなるほどねっ
[音楽]
あ
これで真ん中の名も g o 相手がでるかこっちがたちを豪雨で相手な花を
で最高僕は僕内海ないかんですけどあーなるほどね
[音楽]
変態仮面
俺ならん
援隊関連
はじめしゃちょー
ちょっとなりましたありがとうございますこれでは真ん中売った人かもと気がするなん
だけど
なるほどこれがりなちゃんりんなちゃんとマッチングしましたけどね
まんだから店まできたぞ
最初の後物の相手を鈍くされますはい学
[音楽]
うコア
強ユーチューバーてきている
パズル社長は
ちょっとへ壊れこれなにこれなにこれでこいよ
youtube
肇社長は
神っての桜いい子でニナチャーン
風情ありがとうございます奴はねはずビス中身って最高ですねありがとう
背負っちゃうかねモーターはすげーなーいい子っていいアプリですね
このアプリのユーザーは良い子がたくさんいるかもしれませんねこれおもろいな
ごめん膝はとマッチングしましたよろしくお願いますねしま小町
とっ
カブテープ
[音楽]
再生回数
全然ななんじゃないよねかじゃないガムテープ
再生回数稼げる
いやー数いえばそんな思いますありがとうございます
僕はちょっとひどいととマッチングしましたよろしくお願いします
次はいきなり続けてみましょうかおいお前からやろ
[音楽]
何でしょはいと思いましたおいお前
何でしょう
風邪ひくないを整えましたありがとうございます聖さんと間違いですよろしくお願いし
ますねはい真ん中でもこれ競っても揃いな相手の初手が見てるんで
さあどうぞ
ハート柄
[音楽]
いやいやどうぞさあどうぞと言われたんですければ選定は it 方なので相手を立た
せなければいけないけど
いやいやどうぞという解消中でいただきますがさあどうかえってくるのでしょうか
さあどうぞ
いやいやどうぞ
じゃあ俺があっはいが自分から身を乗り出していってくださいましたねディズニーさん
ありがとうございます4つ最初のもずれしていきます
何才な止めもやばいなこれ
あのだからやばいなリンピックの試合インターミディあってな
早速がに考えるかこれをことそれで6つ
敗となりました何才な
今年てベッツ
腹は会2
ありがとうございました彼女のボディ最後の5文字が分かりましたよろしくお願います
組食べてと送りました相手は返答末です
はい食べました組食べて
喉に詰まった倖田來未
ありがとうございます
いやらしい
いやらしいかなら水を
体がターン等帰ってくるでしょいやらしい
顔と体がいい
あっ
ウエートでラメダサいん
[音楽]
あのブロ1日いたなさあどう出てくるでしょうか
さみんなプロ
1日たらーん
干からびた
名前離れるんじゃなくても本人っていうのが良いと思います
目星さんよろしくお願いします真ん中なのもわかりますね
あなただね大行きもストレートの質問からあなただれ肇社長よって編とマジ
あなた誰
はじめしゃちょーよ
絵本ものパンツ
必要様勝つとあったみたいなビッグですね素敵ですありがとうございます
あのごぼうかな
[音楽]
高尾棒からん
いや違うよごぼうかな
いいや違うよ
旧理科な親しでも何んがね大谷氏でもないんだ
単位ロシアしますが前からさんよろしくお願います最初のと文字
わかりましたこんばんはでいました
君の花とに
はい整いましたしましたしますこんばんは君のハートに
こんばんははい綺麗で受けたらしましたありがとうございます
始め1位
ほいうん本物よと話しますすげーなー配合し都合オンラインで初めてってたら気も
気づいてくれる方が多くて嬉しいです
背景は者へはじめうん本物よ
騙されねーよほんままだぁー
[音楽]
me